bonjour bienvenue à strasbourg nous
sommes ensemble pour 30 minutes
d'actualité européenne dans europe hebdo
dans cette émission direction l'ukraine
depuis trois mois les opposants au
président ianoukovitch campaient place
maïdan à kiev la semaine dernière les
violences ont repris bilan 80 de mort et
la communauté internationale s'active
pour sortir le pays du blocage politique
et économique mais d'abord l'actualité
vous pensiez en avoir fini avec les
organismes génétiquement modifiés et
bien pas vraiment alors faut-il
s'attendre à avoir des ogm dans notre
assiette c'est la question de la semaine
on pensait en avoir terminé
après tout on avait voté un moratoire
non les ogm pas chez nous jamais pensé
travailler à une agriculture durable
respectueuse et la
faute de consensus au sein des 28 lors
d'une réunion des ministres des affaires
européennes
voilà que la commission autorise la
culture du maïs tc 15 07 du fabricant
pioneer contre l'avis de la majorité des
états membres et du parlement européen
branle bas de combat la france se dit
déterminée à interdire la culture sur
son sol mais le sénat rejette la
proposition de loi est depuis des années
le conseil d'état casse tous les
moratoires et autres clauses de
sauvegarde arguant du manque d'éléments
scientifiques nouveaux pouvant les
risques des organismes génétiquement
modifiés
alors pourquoi ne pas cultiver les ogm
alors à quand les ogm dans notre
assiette et alors qui mieux que josé
bové pour répondre à cette question
bonjour merci d'être avec nous bonjour
donc on ne vous présente plus vous êtes
vice-président ici au sein de ce
parlement de la commission agriculture
et développement rural et vous êtes
candidat à la présidence de la
commission européenne pour les verts
européens avec ce cas quelle heure
allemande
josé bosé après tout ce tintouin là on
en parle depuis des années des ogm
pourquoi est-ce contesterait pas
finalement écouté jeu sont assez simples
il y a eu une étude indépendante qui
avait été faite par le docteur séralini
sur les aspects sanitaires elle a été
contestée invalidait allaitent elle
était contestée par beaucoup de gens moi
j'en ai parlé avec l'agencé européenne
sanitaire des aliments ils sont d'accord
pour dire il faut mettre en place un
protocole scientifique sur cette
question des risques à long terme pour
la santé donc maintenant ce qu'on attend
simplement et il ça devrait se faire
dans les mois qui viennent que l' agence
européenne et des agences nationales se
mettent d'accord sur le protocole
scientifique avec aussi des chercheurs
indépendants et qu'on lance ce processus
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut faire
puisque ça n'a jamais été fort aux
internationaux à date heure le
professeur séralini donc à monter en
fait une étude sur six mois je crois sur
nogent 2 heures pardon sur des rails
s'est avéré en fait que l'ingestion à
long terme en fait dodo gm a provoqué en
fait des cancers du foie des
excroissances s'en souvient un petit peu
tous de ces images effectivement sera
complètement déformés donc cette étude a
été invalidée et ne fait plus partie de
la littérature scientifique
est ce qu'au fond
on peut faire confiance en fait à ces
études là le problème c'est que depuis
des années on demande à ce qu'il y ait
des études qu'ils soient organisés au
niveau européen et avec les pays membres
de manière complètement indépendant
c'est quelque chose grâce je dirais à
l'étude de monsieur séralini qui a
montré semble-t-il un certain nombre d'
un support mais moi je suis pas
scientifique non plus tout le monde se
met d'accord pose et il faut le faire
donc mettons en oeuvre cette étude et on
aura comme ça des éléments qui ne
pourront plus être discuté ou qui
pourront permettre d'autres étudiants
c'est pourquoi on ne fait pas cette
étude où est le problème finalement
scellé fond c'est quoi les fausses et
par un véritable problème parce que
c'est relativement limité on parle de 3
millions à peu près pour mener cette
étude donc c'est quelque chose c'est au
niveau européen est tout à fait possible
maintenant il faut qu'il y ait une
volonté politique et que l' agence
européenne et le feu vert pour le faire
donc j'espère que dans les prochains
mois les choses vont demeurer ça a été
actée comme une nécessité donc tout le
monde est d'accord alors moi je vais je
vais jouer un petit peu l'avocat du
diable mais après tout aux états unis on
en mange depuis 15 ans sans que ça pose
particulièrement le problème semble-t-il
on en importe on importe entre 300000 et
500 mille tonnes enfin je j'ai pu
exactement les chiffres en tête mais
après tout il n'ya pas une forme de je
dirais de de cynisme à se dire non nous
on veut pas en cultiver mais on continue
d'en importer la plupart des bêtes en
fait en mange donc pourquoi pas pourquoi
pas en cultiver finalement alors d'abord
sur les études sanitaires comme on l'a
dit si on ne veut pas chercher on trouve
pas donc à partir du moment n'y a pas
d'étude on peut pas savoir quelles sont
les conséquences sanitaires mais
d'autres problèmes se posent des
problèmes environnementaux
les transfert de gène sur les autres
cultures donc ça ça pose un véritable
problème
les problèmes sur les insectes non
ciblés qui deviennent résistants y
compris des insectes possible donc les
générations futures sont beaucoup plus
résistant les plantes qui deviennent
elles-mêmes résistantes aux herbicides
et ce faisant les mauvaises herbes entre
guillemets de la même manière deviennent
résistants ça pose énormément de
problèmes de stocks ont approuvé très
large y compris des problèmes
économiques pour savoir
si ça va pas entraîner des distorsions
de concurrence donc tout ça doit être
étudiée et mis au même niveau que les
questions sanitaires bon alors josé bové
vous venez de publier en fait ce livre
qui est absolument incroyable puisqu'il
s'appelle hold up à bruce aller et on
lit ça vraiment comme un polar vous nous
raconter en fait les arcanes de toutes
ces agences et notamment
l'efsa donc l' agence européenne qui en
charge entre autres de la question des
ogm
et vous pointer les problèmes en fait
des lobbys et des conflits d'intérêts
entre les gens qui sont à la tête de
cette agence et l'industrie
agroalimentaire les biotechnologies et c
est ce qu on n'a pas un petit peu
laisser bruxelles et notamment ses
agences aux mains de de ces industries
agroalimentaire et biotechnologique
alors il faut rappeler que donc cette
agence européenne sanitaire des aliments
aesa en français efsa en anglais est né
en 2002 après la crise de la vache folle
et c'était effectivement donc un progrès
c'était quelque chose d'important à
mettre en oeuvre pour étudier l'ensemble
des questions c'est pas simplement les
ogm ce sont les pesticides les colorants
l'aspartame tous ces sujets sont
étudiées par cette agence le problème
c'est que ça a été mis en oeuvre et en
fait y'a pas eu véritablement de
contrôle derrière pour vérifier comment
ça fonctionnait et je me suis rendu
compte en étant ici au parlement
européenne qui avait des choses bizarres
d'abord les experts souvent viennent de
l'industrie premier problème souvent les
éléments qui certes a analysé par
exemple les ogm sont directement les
éléments fournis par monsanto donc
monsanto dépose une demande de nouvel
ogm et on les teste à partir des normes
de monsanto ça pose évidemment à
deuxième problème est le troisième
problème je dirais le plus grand c'est
que je me suis rendu compte et je menais
l'enquète que la présidente de cette
agence était elle même issue du plus
gros lobby de l'agro alimentaire mondial
qui s'appelle l'ilsi qui est un sigle
pas du tout connu qui a des antennes
dans tous les continents et cette
personne était membre du conseil
d'administration et elle l'avait caché
donc c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
incroyable et quand le parlement
européen suite à ma révélation
s'est rendu compte de cela et bien a
refusé de voter le quitus à cette agence
et cette personne a été contrainte de
démissionner là on était vraiment dans
le conflit d'intérêt majeur je conseille
effectivement la lecture parce que ça
c'est vraiment comme un polar josé bové
je disais tout à l'heure que vous étiez
aussi candidat à la présidence de la
commission pour les verts je voudrais
qu'on écoute une de vos potentiels entre
guillemets
votre consoeur au sein de ce parlement
est votre adversaire politique on écoute
est-ce que vous effectuerez tout votre
mandat de député européen s'il est élu
et bien sûr en mai prochain el ghazi
rejetée par attend là bas je ne sais pas
si ça se trouve je serai élue présidente
de la république en 2010 est serait
obligé d'interrompre son mandat de
député européen
j'ai pas pour toute la législature
européenne
abbassi les français décident de me
porter à l'elysée présidentielle mais
aussi les jeux pan tilt je pense qu
nettement mes électeurs le comprendront
donc trait d'humour de marine le pen sur
le plateau de public sénat il ya
quelques jours
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ces
sondages qui indiquent que le front
national est aujourd'hui le premier
parti de france à ce qu'elle à quoi vous
vous attendez lors de l'élection du 25
mai prochain les choses sont en train de
bouger et je crois que les français
notamment mais je pense que c'est la
réalité pour les autres européens sont
en train de se rendre compte aujourd'hui
qu'il n'y a pas de solutions aux crises
je dire au pluriel économique sociale ou
environnementale sans un renforcement en
europe aujourd'hui la solution des
crises passent par l'europe si on veut
faire en sorte qu'ils aient une
harmonisation sociale et fiscale
si on veut permettre aux jeunes de
retrouver de l'emploi ça va passer par
l'europe la reconversion écologique de
l'industrie pour faire face au
changement climatique ça passe par
l'europe donc il va falloir investir au
niveau européen dont je crois que
là-dessus des gens se sont en train de
se rendre compte et si on demande aux
français concrètement si on va en safin
catégorie par catégorie sociale les gens
ne rejette pas l'europe au contraire
simplement ils ne veulent pas de cette
europe là et je crois que c'est ça la
grande différence les gens sont prêts
européens mais ils n'acceptent pas une
europe qui soit technocratique alors les
gens sont pro européen ça ça reste
effectivement à démontrer
quand vous voulez bon là en attendant
quand on entend parler c'est plutôt
l'europe c'est plutôt l'europe des
banques et pas l'europe des peuples on
veut la même chose pour ça non on veut
changer d'europe les gens ne remettent
pas même le rhône d'accord avec jean
françois copé qui pourrait dire j'aime
tellement l'europe que je vais la
changer
je trouve intéressant de voir monsieur
copé dire cela alors qu'ils restent dans
un modèle très anciens d'europe
intergouvernementale aujourd'hui quand
on dit plus d'europe ça veut dire qu'il
faut les aider il faut une souveraineté
c'est ce que dit daniel cohn-bendit il
faut les états unis transcrivez ça je
vais réalisme européen je crois qu'il
faut aller plus haut à 0 caution veut
garder une souveraineté française il
faut renforcer la souveraineté
européenne
et quand on voit ce qui se passe à kiev
avec des gens qui brandissent le drapeau
européen c'est pas pour entrer demain
dans l'europe mais c'est pour dire ce
sont les valeurs de démocratie et
transparence qu'on veut chez nous alors
justement la transition à l'impeccable
parce que justement on va partir à kiev
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la position
de l'europe sur ce conflit en ukraine
est ce qu'on n'a pas été trop tard et
pas assez vite je pense qu'il ya eu un
certain nombre de d'atermoiements qui
ont été à mon avis négatif on aurait dû
taper l'europe madame ashton aurait dû
taper du poing sur la table beaucoup
plus vite il faut qu'on aide d'abord les
ukrainiens à faire des élections qui
soient vraiment transparent prévu
vincent qui sont prévues le même jour
que l'élection européenne c'est un petit
clin d'oeil mais qui est très
intéressant ça c'est le premier sac et
puis ensuite il va falloir organiser une
réunion des donateurs pour véritablement
médecin 9 mais pourquoi il faudra faire
attention que ça soit pas une réunion
technocratique qui est vraiment des
responsables politiques et qu'on assène
pas au peuple ukrainien un régime
absolument insupportable merci josé bové
justement nous on continue direction
place maïdan depuis trois mois les
opposants au président ianoukovitch
campaient sur cette bien nommée place de
l'indépendance motif l'arrêt brutal des
négociations avec l'europe et le retour
entre guillemets dans le giron russe et
une corruption endémique de la part des
gouvernants nous étions à kiev pour
rencontrer un petit peu les
protagonistes quand la révolte a éclaté
bilan une centaine de morts et depuis
les instances internationales sont au
chevet de l'ukraine c'est un reportage
de jérôme rabelais
20h place maidana kiev le mardi 18
février
la police charge les manifestants
installés là depuis plus de trois mois
une union de la révolution ukrainienne h
en double masculin
la veille encore le calme régnait comme
depuis trois semaines manifestants et
policiers se font face dans une rue qui
borde la place est sur les barricades on
réclame encore et toujours le départ du
président
est là pour que ianoukovitch taille
dégage sale criminels dégage
il est au pouvoir depuis quatre ans
quatre ans et rien n'a changé combien de
gens sont en difficulté combien sont
dans la pauvreté les pensions de
retraite c'est 600 700 grivnas on ne
peut pas vivre avec ça le gaz est cher
le prix des aliments augmentent tout
devient plus cher
dans ce no man's land le sol témoignent
des affrontements les côtés policiers le
discours est à la baisse
ce sont des ukrainiens comme nous je ne
les considère pas comme des criminels
il faut espérer qu'il n'y aura plus
d'événements comme ceux de janvier que
nos hommes politiques seront
suffisamment raisonnables et patient
pour trouver une solution parce que
l'affrontement ce n'est pas bien c'est
un chemin qui mène nulle part c'est pour
cela qu'il doit trouver un compromis
fin novembre 2013 à la surprise générale
le président est très bien viktor
ianoukovitch refuse de signer un accord
commercial et d'association avec l'union
européenne ils préfèrent se tourner vers
moscou qui offre 15 milliards de dollars
et arabes et sur les prix du gaz car les
caisses du pays sont vides le défaut de
paiement n'est pas loin une mauvaise
stratégie pour igor bourakovski
économistes à kiev
est clair que l'harmonisation de notre
marché avec le marché européen c'est un
vrai investissement pour le futur car il
s'agit de réformes structurelles dont
l'ukraine a besoin
aux abords de la place les manifestants
se prépare un nouvel affrontement ici
l'accord avec le est passée au second
plan la priorité désormais au départ du
président
dans les rues les milices d'autodéfense
côtoient des femmes et des hommes de
tous âges pas question pour eux de
lâcher la place maïdan devenu le symbole
de l'ukraine indépendante et cadogo
dédommagement peu plus les gens sont à
bout ce sont les ukrainiens intelligents
qui sont ici vous comprenez les gens
sont à bout tout le monde doit être
présent ici rien fait contre le déni du
goûter ou était-ce pas de match dont
vous n'avez pas honte de nous regarder
dans les yeux mais dont vous n'avez pas
honte mais vous n'avez pas
ya tout moche je suis là parce que nous
voulons tous vivre dans un pays
différent dans un pays où les lois sont
respectées willy un véritable état de
droit pas dans un pays dirigé par des
lois faites par des criminels ou la
règle le pistonnage et ou un clan
s'accapare toutes les richesses
l'état de droit un voeu pieux depuis
décembre de nombreux manifestants
disparus ont été torturées ou
emprisonnés la contestation s'organise
et des associations de tente de protéger
les droits des opposants soldats se
tient euros maidan sos bonjour d'abord
je vous écoute nice-matin anatole tombe
bien qu en ukraine il existe la
présomption d'innocence ce n'est pas
respecter tous les arrêtés d'euros
maidan sont par exemple ranger dans la
catégorie criminelle
déçu par l'attentisme européen les
insurgés de maidan n'espère plus grand
show du vieux continent mme yade on est
chauds starmania je pense que la
position des manifestants de maidana
évoluer vis-à-vis de l'europe on est
passé d'un certain romantisme un euro
réalisme ils comprennent désormais que
la situation en ukraine doit être décidé
par les ukrainiens eux mêmes
les trois mois de contestation déjà
apporté un petit souffle de liberté des
médias indépendants non détenues par des
hommes politiques des oligarques proche
de la russie ont émergé à expresso tv
chaîne diffuse en 24 heures sur 24 sur
internet est lancé au moment des
événements on aspire à être un acteur du
changement catherine toro hier les
manifestions d'oran my dad se sont
rassemblés devant le domicile du
procureur général ukrainien viktor
pchonka
j'adorerais pensé et je pense que notre
chaîne est un des déclencheurs qui peut
permettre d'accompagner le changement
c'est ça qui est beau dans cette
situation parce que vous pouvez voir que
des gens normaux des journalistes des
militants de tous bords viennent sur
scène et 10 vous pouvez faire changer
les choses vous pouvez changer les
choses et c'est pour cela que ça vaut le
coup de faire ce travail que ça vaut le
coup de rester ici en ukraine
plus de vingt ans après la chute du bloc
soviétique
l'ukraine cherche encore sa place entre
russie et europe l'aspiration à plus de
liberté à sonner la révolte reste à
connaître le prix à pékin
où va l'ukraine c'est la question que je
vais poser à nos deux invités bonjour
marielle de sarnez vous revenez de kiev
vous avez été avec certaines personnes
de votre groupe libéraux démocrates la
semaine dernière brice hortefeux vous
êtes également par lino vous êtes député
de membre du parti populaire européen on
ne vous présente plus marielle de sarnez
quel a été votre sentiment quand vous
étiez sur place j'avais déjà été sur
place le 8 décembre lors des grandes
manifestations qui avaient lieu après la
première impression savez quand les
mails les forces armées sont arrivés sur
la place le matin à 5 heures du matin
qu'ils ont faits prisonniers très très
nombreux étudiants ce qui avait beaucoup
touché les ukrainiens même bouleversé
ces images les ukrainiens et en fait
c'était un sentiment très différents lui
décembre c'était une espèce d'euphorie
d' enthousiasme il était là sur la place
à brandir des drapeaux ukrainiens et
européens dans une révolution heureuse
comme ça et puis là c'était une tout
autre ambiance était au lendemain de
tous ces morts c'était une ambiance
absolument glaçante la place était noire
elle avait été brûlée
il y avait une une amertume et en même
temps une détermination et une colère
extrêmement fortes dans la nuit où je
suis allé à maidan avec guy verhostadt
donc une ambiance très différente d'un
peuple qui avait vu les siens tombés
sous les balles
ordonnée par le président donc c'était
quelque chose d'extrêmement l'eau et
puis ensuite les événements se sont
accélérés extrêmement rapidement c'est à
dire qu'en fait en 24 heures tout a
basculé la médiation européenne est
arrivée sur place qui était une bonne
chose avec le ministre et sa place
trangères français je dis que c'est une
bonne chose parce qu'on a toujours des
médiations qui sont plutôt ceux toujours
les polonais ou les allemands qui sont
présents en ukraine que la france était
là c'était bien on peut dire que c'était
peut-être peut-être un peu trop tard
justement je vais vous poser la question
mais alors là ça a fonctionné justement
brice hortefeux on a vu certaines une
notamment de libération qui disait
l'ukraine trahi par l'europe en soi est
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ce
constat
c'est un constat qui est un constat qui
doit être honnête et lucide et quel est
ce constat d'abord c'est que la france a
été absente en vérité ensuite que la
france au sein de l'europe a elle même
été absente et que
l'europe a été trop absents en clair la
france elle était absente on a une
démonstration qui est flagrante hélas
c'est que dans la semaine qui a précédé
le départ du président est chrétien et
barack obama s'est entretenu à trois
reprises avec la chancelière angela
merkel à deux reprises avec damien david
cameron pas avec le président français
deuxième observation au sein de l'europe
la france ne s'est pas particulièrement
fait entendre et enfin l'europe oui a
été un peu absente un peu trop absente
un peu trop lente à quoi le voit-on on
le voit dans la durée parce que l'europe
n'a pas su établir un dialogue avec les
russes et on sait que la question
ukrainienne repose sur un dialogue avec
eux la russie pour une raison simple
c'est que la russie c'est en gros le
tiers de la population ukrainienne qui
est russophone et une partie de la
population à l'ouest qui est le plus tôt
européenne et donc ça pas sauter
automatiquement par ce dialogue et ce
dialogue n'a pas existé donc on paie
effectivement un retard pardonnez moi
l'expression à l'allumage alors
justement ce retard à l'allumage on a un
problème aujourd'hui de crise financière
en ukraine ce qui les a poussés
d'ailleurs au mois de décembre a arrêté
à se tourner plutôt vers la russie on
estime à 35 milliards en fait les
besoins de l'ukraine est-ce que c'est à
l'europe de payer ou com
on semble le voir aujourd'hui aux jeunes
récents oui c'est un trailer accumulés
au fond depuis dix ans l'ukraine c'était
un payés avec des ressources extrait
sain bel riche potentiellement mais qui
a une économie et d'agriculture qui
doivent être modernisées et donc ils
sont dans une très mauvaise situation
économique
ils sont dans une mauvaise situation
économique parce qu'ils n'ont pas fait
les réformes nécessaires chez eux et ils
sont dans une mauvaise situation
économique parce qu'ils ont justement
cette relation avec la russie bien sûr
qu'il faut qu'on parle avec la russie
c'est évident qu'on va pas écartelée
l'ukraine entre l'europe et la russie
elle regarde vers l'europe parce que
l'europe elle la voit comme une
perspective de progrès or ils ont besoin
d'un progrès démocratique et économique
et en même temps évidemment qu'ils ont
une histoire et une frontière commune
avec la russie mais par exemple prix du
gaz le fait que ça fasse le yoyo et que
la russie en effet au fond un argument
politique de chantage politique depuis
des années c'est paraissant avec les
traîne avec des plus du gaz très très
haut par moments évidemment tout ceci
fragilisation de nombreuses crises
deuxième quand on dit mais les russes
ont donné trois billards ils n'ont
peut-être pas donné les 3 milliards qui
viennent à qui il a laissé 3 milliards
là vous savez le cren c'est un des pays
le système politique ukrainien pas le
pays deux systèmes politiques est un des
plus corrompus de la planète et tous les
gens tous tout le monde a vu tous les
téléspectateurs la maison de
ianoukovitch la maison en la maison
l'odyssée landais voile à un ris
ianoukovitch et donc où aller cet argent
alors maintenant la question c'est que
cet argent il doit aller l'europe doit t
dès demain elle a des instruments pour
le faire elle doit aider à
l'investissement parce qu'au fond
investissements ces réformes
structurelles réformes de structure
alors est-ce qu'on a les moyens brice
hortefeux d'aider l'ukraine à l'heure où
il a fallu aider chypre la grèce
c'est là la question ne porte pas de la
même dimension et l'ukraine en résumé
c'est la population de l'espagne avec
un produit intérieur brut qui est celui
du portugal donc on mesure avec ces deux
éléments est toute la question tout le
défi que l'on doit relever il ya une
réalité c'est que l'ukraine avait un
potentiel de croissance très important
qui dépassé les 5% qui est tombé
malheureusement à deux et que l'ukraine
à 72 75 milliards de dettes et notamment
28 28 à l'égard de la russie c'est donc
là encore une fois souligner toute la
difficulté qui doit être que l'europe
doit surmonter pour aider ce pays
aujourd'hui l'europe s'oriente vers une
position qui à mon avis n'est pas
satisfaisante puisque l'europe a
tendance à dire que c'est le fmi qui
doit y faire face c'est donc un sujet
dont nous devons nous emparer et
d'ailleurs lors du congrès du ppe de
groupes politiques qui se tient la
semaine prochaine à dublin nous
accueillerons
qui viendra s'exprimer et rappelé le
besoin l'opposant historique incarcéré
l'ancien premier ministre et vie qui
viendra exprimé les besoins de l'ukraine
à cette occasion alors il y avait un des
intervenants ce reportage qui avait une
remarque à vous adresser directement on
les écoute
affectés ou neutres vraiment parler
d'une intégration avec l'union
européenne efficace si la majorité des
ukrainiens n'ont jamais traversé la
frontière avec lui
en fait nous sommes séparés de l'europe
par un mur de papier par un mur des
visas et de la pauvreté
sk pas une part de cynisme de parler
effectivement de l'ukraine petite soeur
entre guillemets de l'europe et de
laisser ses et craignant en dehors de
cette frontière si la question et
l'ukraine doit-elle adhérer rapidement
l'union européenne la réponse est non
elle n'en a pas aujourd'hui les moyens
la possibilité et l'europe n'a pas les
moyens et la possibilité de les
accueillir pour des raisons d'ailleurs
économique financière que je viens de
raku à bartenheim
maintenant ce qui était envisagé c'était
un par nos partenariats privilégiés
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui était l'une des
causes de
ce qui s'est déroulé et du père
donnez-moi d'ivoire aussi un symbole
très fort nous sommes aujourd'hui
engagés dans une période où il y aura
des élections européennes c'est à dire
que les citoyens européens devront se
prononcer et on sent dans un grand
nombre de pays des 28 pays de la
communauté européenne
un scepticisme à l'égard de l'europe et
bien finalement ce qui s'est passé en
ukraine c'est aussi une leçon pour nous
européens cela nous rappelle que
l'europe suscite des envies et des
espoirs et donc c'est un élément aussi
très positif vous êtes d'accord marielle
de sarnez est-ce qu'il faut laisser
l'ukraine en dehors
de l'europe entre guillemets il faut
qu'on se comprenne que ce qui se passe
en ukraine là il ya évidemment cette
demande de perspectives mais c'est parce
que pour eux l'europe il est vécu comme
un levier vraiment de progrès il faut
vraiment comprendre ça les ukrainiens
qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent qu'ils soient
de l'ouest ou de l'ouest ou de l'est ils
veulent en finir avec la corruption ils
veulent vivre décemment ils veulent
aussi au fond bénéficier des valeurs
aujourd'hui européenne est à de droit
liberté de la presse justice
indépendante respect des libertés
individuelles et publiques qu'ils n'ont
pas chez eux donc ils sont privés de
chez eux ça c'est le premier point est
donc il faut qu'on soit à leurs côtés
pour favoriser cette transition
démocratique et ses réformes économiques
dont ils ont besoin c'est très important
pour soient vigilants et à leurs côtés
et puis après il ya la question de
l'avenir de l'europe il faut repenser
l'architecte de l'europe plus
d'intégration d'un côté et en même temps
avoir cette europe qui peut être
effectivement apaisé et puissante sur le
continent européen alors dernière
question est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre à
une partition on voit qu'il ya des
tensions quand même entre 7 du cren de
l'ouest et 7 ukraine de l'est qui
regardent plus vers la russie imaginer
que l'ukraine peut se stabilise et
demain sans un dialogue au fond entre la
russie l'ukraine et l'europe se raconter
des histoires on a besoin évidemment de
parler avec poutine mais poutine a
besoin d'entendre aussi que l'ukraine a
son propre avenir à écrire est ce que
vous êtes d'accord brice hortefeux est
ce qu'on peut parler avec vladimir
poutine c'est fait la question n'est pas
de le pouvoir c'est un devoir et
précisément l'enjeu c'est d'éviter une
partition de l'ukraine et il ya
certainement des tentations et il faut
donc les dépasser comment les dépasser
la solution elle est très simple très
claire elle et j'allais dire quasi
unique cela passe par un dialogue entre
l'union européenne et la russie et cela
doit te reposer sur une évolution de la
conception du dialogue entre l'union
européenne et
le voisin russe parce que jusqu'à
présent ce dialogue était extrêmement
faible écoutez merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec vous pour évoquer ce dossier
risque nous on continue bien entendu à
suivre cette question rendez vous en
attendant la semaine prochaine avec
ahmed tazir à bruxelles bonne suite de
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires